you J need to first take a victory lap
because the ACLJ your group were you're
the chief counsel you led this case in
the IRS they did weaponize the IRS they
did turn them against anybody that was
conservative Tea Party oriented a big
win but Obama kind of also got what he
wanted yeah well I mean look it took
three and a half years of litigation to
get there our team did a fantastic job
of litigating this and the end result is
not only an acknowledgment of the
wrongdoing but also a complete change of
policies there will be an order signed
by the court in the next week or ten
days that's gonna include declaratory
relief meaning that the policies will go
forward and they will not be able to do
what they did which is violate the First
Amendment and I you know whether you're
right left or Center the idea that the
government would target somebody because
of the name of the organization or the
political position they were exposing
violates the fundamental aspects of
freedom of speech freedom of association
and we've now got an agreement with that
so it's a very good day for our clients
but Shawn it was three and a half years
a lot of those groups as you know we're
not able to continue to activate him by
the way it wasn't just Tea Party groups
there were groups in that were just
because of the name that they had in
their organization they were targeted
for this and that really beyond the pale
but the end resettlement in April of
2010 I was in Atlanta it was like 25,000
people there are people all over the
country massive crimes that were
energized these groups formed they
wanted to oppose Obama's policies and
they got stopped in their tracks
so this they'd have a big impact got a
good we got a fit we got a result but
you know the harm was done there's no
question about I'm glad the case is over
glad it's resolved glad the government
took the liability and the
responsibility that they did for
wrongdoing but it took three and a half
years of litigation to get there glad we
won glad it got resolved glad General
Sessions attorney General Sessions
signed the is it moved this forward he
issued a statement today but at the end
of the day three and a half years of
litigation to do what depend a
fundamental right on the First Amendment
should have never happened in the first
place